There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of the
most-hyped products from June
to test for ourselves.
I did it.
I bought the Jones Road
Beauty What the Foundation.
This has caused all kinds of
controversy and discourse,
so I apologize for also
putting in my 2 cents.
This is what it looks like.
It's very oily and thick.
It has a scent I actually don't mind.
It's like a soft, spa-like smell.
I applied a pretty small
amount for me with my fingers
and then went over that with my sponge,
and I did not hate how this looked.
It's very skin-like.
It felt like I wasn't
even wearing foundation.
I will say it tends to
gather in certain areas,
so I might have to go in
with even less product.
My other products layered
on top of this fine,
but I feel like I like this more
as an everyday skin tint
rather than a foundation
base for my makeup.
Like, I would reach for this
when I'm running errands
on a Sunday morning,
but not when I'm going to the club.
I've been obsessed with lip oil,
so I immediately snapped up
this Fenty Beauty Cherry Treat
conditioning and strengthening lip oil.
I have to start off by saying
this is the most
amazing-smelling lip product.
It smells like cherry candies.
We got this giant doe-foot
applicator I love.
I did not want to stop applying this.
It felt so nice.
This formula makes your lips feel
so hydrated and soft and cushiony,
if that makes any sense.
It's also so glossy.
The color is so sheer
it doesn't really look
like much on my lips,
but I love this,
and it's definitely going in my bag.
I also got the Fenty Beauty
Poutsicle hydrating lip stain.
This also feels so good on the lips.
Every lip stain I've tried
has been more drying, not hydrating,
so I am really into this formula.
It's very pigmented,
so I was careful when I was applying
to make sure I didn't
get the stain anywhere
outside of my lips.
After leaving it on for a few minutes,
I wiped it off with a paper towel,
and there was definitely
a pretty stain left behind
that was 100% transfer-proof.
I can see myself wearing
this a lot this summer.
If you can believe it,
I have never tried a
Haus Labs product before.
They recently rebranded,
and I picked up a couple of products.
First up, this Haus Labs
Hy-Power pigment paint.
You can use this anywhere on the face.
The pigment in these
actually took me by surprise.
Like, I was not expecting
them to be so full-coverage.
You need the tiniest amount of these.
It blended out pretty easily on my eyes,
and it doesn't dry too quickly,
so you have some time to work.
I am so into these.
I also picked up the PhD hybrid lip oil.
This applicator is much
smaller than the Fenty one,
which made me sad,
but the actual formula is really smooth
and comfortable on the lips.
It's more of a thinner formula
than other lip oils I've tried,
but I really loved how
this looked and felt.
This also has no scent,
which I prefer over a bad scent.
These were great products,
and I need to try more.
Uoma Beauty just released
this Trippin smooth powder,
and what's so cool about it
is how the powder dispenses.
You twist it,
and it releases the
perfect amount of powder,
which I love because my
powders get so messy.
The powder itself is so finely
milled and silky smooth.
It applied really nicely
and smoothed out my under-eyes a bit,
so I really liked it.
I've been on the hunt for
a good talc-free powder,
and I think this is it.
The only thing I wish they had
was a translucent option,
but this is so good.
I tried two products
from Makeup Revolution.
Let's start with this
Blush Bomb cream blusher.
This straight up looks and
feels like a lip gloss.
It was very confusing.
It's definitely more of
an oily blush formula
than I'm used to.
First application wasn't great.
It's pretty sheer, but it does build up.
I don't think I like this, though.
I think it just feels like
lip gloss on my cheeks.
I also tried the Superfix misting spray.
I know I just complained
about the blush looking like a lip gloss,
but I love that this
looks like a hair spray.
The mist is nice,
but I wish it was a continuous mist.
I applied this underneath my makeup
and then on top when I was finished.
That's how I like to use setting spray.
It melted the makeup in nicely,
but I typically like a more dewy finish,
and this is pretty matte.
I wore this makeup for eight hours,
and I think I looked OK
at the end of the day.
I feel like I could still see my blush,
which is usually the
first thing to disappear.
This isn't my favorite setting spray,
but I do think it's a good cheaper option.
Pat McGrath released a new shade
of her Skin Fetish
highlighter and balm duo.
This has a balm on one side
and this really beautiful
highlighter on the other.
This shade, Xtreme Cyber
Orchid, is so interesting.
It shifts from a blue to a lilac
and totally disappears at certain angles.
This formula is definitely balmy,
but not in an oily way.
I got so nervous when I first applied it,
because this was not blending in at all,
but it blended in really nicely
when I used my fingers.
I think for 58 bucks I would rather get
a more wearable everyday shade,
but this formula is really nice.
This is the Maybelline Tattoo
Studio brow-lift stick,
which is supposed to give you a brow lift
or a brow-lamination effect at home.
It has a cool little brush on one side
and then this colored wax on the other.
So you brush your brows up first,
apply the wax to fill in,
and then use the brush
to lift the brow hairs.
This is a cool idea,
and I did like how it made my brows look,
but it did take a bit of work.
I think if this brush had firmer bristles,
it would be easier to get
that brow-lift effect.
I also just don't think
this wax is waxy enough
to hold my brows up all
day, so this was just OK.